i thought this film was beautifully done
it obviously has some very dark subject
matter so very much so yeah all of that
[Laughter]
yeah it's one of those it's yeah it's i
saw the movie for the first time last
night on a big screen and it really you
know brings it home how dark and you
know brutal some of the scenes are it
really doesn't shy away from it i mean i
knew it when we were filming but to see
it on screen is a whole different level
um but i'm really glad that we you know
we found the right mix of light and dark
and the different shades that um that
the story has it was brilliant to do
yeah yeah it's kind of impressive how it
doesn't leave you with this just awful
feeling when you're totally yeah but it
still manages to find a way to give you
hope and inspire you which is not i mean
i i would imagine that's kind of a
tricky balance yeah it's not an easy
thing to do it's all down to dj and
francine really for writing you know
such an incredible script it was all
there
you really got that you got it from the
page as soon as i read it you kind of
you really felt that mix between
um the light and the dark and what the
film was trying to portray um yeah it
was amazing to work on
well how did you come to this what was
your audition process like for this was
it one of those like crazy long drawn
out processes so i think it was for abby
it was more so i think but she was cast
a couple of months before me and they'd
done a big search to find michael and
luckily i didn't find anybody um so they
came to the uk looking um
and i got the audition through i'd never
read the book before
um so i read the book before my audition
just to prep um i loved it i just i read
it in like one sitting it was just i
love historical fiction so i i was just
i really you know the material really
really resonated with me um and then as
soon as and then i did my first tape um
and went in for the audition with the
casting director and then a couple of
days later i got a call saying dj's
flying from la to see you
um francine loves you you know
oh it looks good and then as soon as i
met the d i
met dj i was just we were just on such
similar mind um wavelengths about how to
do the movie and what the movie should
be and and how to really come at the
character because it's a difficult
character to portray you know he can he
can seem a bit um you know he's he's the
light of the movie and so it's hard to
you know try and get all the different
shades of the character in there but dj
had such a solid um
you know way of thinking about the
character that it was just a dream to
play yeah it was gorgeous and then as
soon as i met dj i think i flew to south
africa in like a week like it was it was
just literally like sort the visa out
and you're straight there for
pre-production so it was amazing we got
a lot of time to prep though so it was
brilliant
yeah i mean this film doesn't work if
the chemistry between angel and michael
isn't there and yeah the audience
doesn't care about them it's very
important yeah yeah
yeah literally as soon as me and abby
met i could sense i could sense like the
producers and dj being like breathing
relief like oh thank goodness that they
like they like each other i mean thank
goodness they get on because you kind of
have to have that chemistry and we did
from the moment we met we we have such
good mates now such good friends and um
yeah from as soon as we made each other
we just hung out um
and spoke about the movie and our lives
and it was you know i'm so thankful that
it's my first movie and it's also abby's
like first really major lead in a movie
so we really
um we were at the same level you know i
mean so i think the nerves between us
were there at the same time so we just
kind of went on this journey together
and we were having we had um we had the
premiere last night and we had a little
glass of champagne before
just to be like how crazy it is like
this is our first big thing and we're
you know promoting it is so exciting you
know we're so proud of like the work
that we did we had to like it was a
surreal moment it was like kind of
chasing each other and being like you
know look what we did look what we
created
all that time ago yeah it was amazing
did you have a moment though before you
got there before you met her where you
were like oh god what happens if this
doesn't work what happens if i don't
like it yeah i was yeah i just knew i
kind of we tried a little over whatsapp
and things and we spoke a little before
i got there and i knew instantly that
you know we were going to get on so i
wasn't i wasn't so worried but yeah
luckily because it doesn't always happen
you know you have to get the right kind
of chemistry um but luckily we did
because you know all my scenes are with
angel mostly and
and
that character relationship is so
integral to the movie without it just
all kind if you don't believe that it
all falls apart and what i'm really
thankful for watching the movie um and
seeing that it does work
is you know it's it's brilliant
yeah how was it to have her as a team
partner to really get into this
relationship because there there are so
many things going on that aren't being
said in the relationship yeah it's all
you know even
just yeah just trying to win her over
without totally especially in those
earlier scenes especially when their
first meeting my favorite scene in the
movie is when they first meet you know
when he goes into the brothel and kind
of sees her for the first time and you
know she's expecting another customer
like all the men that she's met before
and he's you know there's something
different in this guy and and she kind
of feels it as well and he does and you
can see this is kind of like chemistry
threesome between them um it's so
beautiful to to play with that was my
favorite that was what i auditioned with
that early scene and that was my main
first audition and
that i just love playing it so much
because it's almost like i mean it's
love at first sight but it's it's like a
teenage romance you know it's that kind
of it's that flirting that you you know
you don't want to say you like someone
and she doesn't want to admit that she
likes a guy because her experience of
men has been so horrendous before but
she can tell that this guy's different
and you know there's there's a lot of
love in those early scenes it's great
yeah i love the fact that you know just
just by him being a nice guy she doesn't
know how to react to that or deal yes
yeah yeah exactly it's a shark
and it's all it's interesting what you
said about it all being unsaid because
it's those little moments that you kind
of see her in her eyes go oh i like this
guy but i don't want to admit it and he
kind of you know he he just goes in you
know
full full blazing he's just ready to
to you know marry her as soon as he
meets so he's found the one he's not
gonna settle for less and she has to
really um
trust him really it's about finding that
trust between them
um whether she can trust any man you
know she's never trusted a man before
why would she all the men in her life
have treated her horrendously um and so
to her for him to bring out that faith
in her
is kind of beautiful is a beautiful
thing to play
um so yeah we were really lucky
what was it like to figure this guy out
and and figure out how you wanted to
play him because he is somebody who is
so
patient and kind and he just gives her
room to really sort of figure out what
she wants yeah how hard is it to balance
making him a nice guy but still keeping
him believable and genuine yeah and
giving him depth that's really
interesting question yeah because i
discussed it at length with dj in the
audition
we didn't want you know he michael is
the light of the movie and really helps
angel find her you know path um to
self-love um
and so
you know you have to
you can't play it too wishy-washy in a
way you know you know i mean like you
can't um you can't give it two he can't
be an angel he can't be too angelic
about it he has to have depth and you
know he's you know he's a guy who's kind
of tortured himself you know he's not
happy in his life he's not he's not
quite sure why
everything seems to be going well but
he's just not quite found the one he's
not settled down he's a little lonely
there's all these kind of inner aspects
to him that you have to that you have to
portray in order to like you said make
it believable
yeah i mean there's so many times that
you know you don't want him to be
somebody that'll just allow himself to
be walked on either exactly yeah and
he's not you know he gets angry at her
at times and frustrated that she can't
see what he sees um but i think what he
really recognizes is the guilt that she
feels about like her life she you know
she feels so guilty for everything she's
done even though he doesn't you know he
thinks you know it's not your fault
you're not to blame and i think he
recognizes that within her and it's just
him having patience to kind of
you know let her find herself and i'll
be here waiting i'm not going anywhere
so as long as you find yourself you know
i'll just wait you know
yeah i think that's why like the scene
of him crying alone in the barn or the
scene of him
trying to talk himself out of going
after her
those are important moments because even
though they're not hearing a
conversation you understand more about
where he's coming from exactly i agree
so yeah that's a really good point i
think um
you have to have those moments of self
of doubt he's doubting himself the whole
time is this everyone is telling him
this isn't the girl that you should be
ending up with you know she's trouble
she's got this past and this is not for
you and he has to it'd be unbelievable
if if we just showed him as like nope
it's fine everything's going well
whatever whatever but like he has to
have that you know the doubt within him
is like you know am i making the right
decision here this is should i be
waiting for this girl you know he waits
for her for years and like you know
that's a it's a huge it's a huge thing
so to see his um that's why the last
scene is so beautiful because like to
see his um
to see kind of the hope in his eyes
becoming real i mean he's like he's the
whole film is hope and he's just lived
on it for so long it's exciting to
finally you know kind of see it all
explode in the in the final scene
i i also love that we get the friendship
between michael and paul i think it's an
interesting dynamic i i love logan
marshall green as an actor he's
brilliant he was great to work with yeah
yeah i mean what was it like to share
those scenes of him to have him as a
scene partner because he seems like
somebody who really just likes to be in
the moment yeah he does and he's quite
he's intense as an actor he you know he
likes to really like stay a lot in the
character's shoes and he likes to really
go there with the part
i kind of come from a theater background
so that's not really me it's just not
how i work but we really found each
other in the scenes and playing them
especially the fight scene between me
and him was just joy to play because you
really get a sense of history between
them even though in the in the film the
history between them isn't shown it's
it's just you kind of have to go with it
that they've known each other for many
many years um as soon as we had our
first scene
there was the history was there between
us already i mean we didn't have to work
to find it it was just kind of there
they're such different characters you
wouldn't almost expect them to be
friends in a way because they are kind
of so different but i think it's that
difference that really brings their kind
of friendship to life
after
doing this and you know doing such an
intensely emotional role in telling this
story what was the last day on set like
what was the last scene that you shot
how was the hype it was a relief yeah
well because the last day the last scene
that we shot it was the last scene of
the movie for the last day um and south
africa went into lockdown i think like
literally like 24 hours after we shot it
so we had to really shoot the end of the
movie super super fast um so it was it
was very very intense so i think a lot
of us just like went like we were just
like oh i just need to sleep do i mean
we just need to like just decompress
after a very very very intense week but
it was it was incredible to think that
we you know we finally were able to get
it in the can and to get it getting
completed in time we were so so lucky if
it had gone like a day over we'd have
just been you know in quite a bit of a
pickle um and you know that that last
scene is such a we wanted to like make
it's the whole the whole movie is
waiting for this moment you know there's
an incredible moment between michael and
angel
um and we just really wanted to
do it justice so it yeah it took a while
and it's you know happening at sunset so
you only have 10 minutes to shoot
because the light only lasts for 10
minutes so if you don't get it within
that 5 10 minutes you know it's gone um
so yeah there's a lot of pressure but it
was you know dj and abby are so great to
work with that it was
it was easy
you also were in gentleman jack which is
such a great series oh good i'm glad you
like it yeah very different kind of
period piece it is very different yeah
yeah it's a very different story what
did you enjoy about being a part of that
story and telling that story and working
on that and and how
how do you like doing these sort of
period stories
i love them i mean i'm a huge history
buff like i think if i wasn't an actor
i'd have been like some kind of history
academic or something like i really i
live for it um and so to do any kind of
period piece is just such a joy to kind
of do all the research and get your you
know really um involve yourself in that
world as much as you possibly can i
really get off on it um
to work on german jack was amazing yeah
sally wayne wright the writer is you
know my one of my favorite writers of
all time her work on tv
in the uk is just incredible and saran
jones is just amazing in the series it's
an incredible story as well and it's a
story that's i've so i'm from yorkshire
um in the uk and um and it's where it's
it's where the story is based and so to
go up you know i was able to like stay
at my parents house as we were shooting
and so it was amazing and it's the first
job i ever really got i got it straight
out of drama school and so it was just
you know throwing it at the deep end
because it's incred you've seen the
series haven't you yeah it's an
incredible character and so it was just
it was such a joy to um to finally play
but it's yeah very very different from
this much darker even though this this
story of this film is incredibly dark
it's a very it's a yeah it's a dark
what what what do you learn about acting
and about the craft of acting after
doing something like that after doing
this i mean you're still sort of so new
to the whole thing how different did you
feel as an actor now
i mean i feel a lot more confident i'm
like really ready and raring to go for
the next thing like i i really really am
i think i was worried i'm not worried in
a sense but you know i come from i can i
drama school training and i come from a
very like theatrical background and so
that's what i was used to is movies are
very different and it's it's a whole
different way you know acting is acting
but you know the way of you know making
sure the camera and stuff it's all very
it's a different method of working and
so i i feel like i actually love it more
than i thought i would i just might i'd
love to just do you know maybe for the
rest of my life it's it's that kind of
thing of you know you have three months
to just get your head down and you're
just you're on location the whole time
and you're just it's all about the work
that you're creating with other creative
people and it's it's like that's your
one job it's your one prerogative let's
just get this one script down and and to
be so
like to go so in depth with one piece
you know rather than like an eight
episode thing where you're kind of
having to think you've got you so many
different balls to juggle on tv i think
um with filmmaking it's um
the focus is a lot stronger
and i really like that way of working
it's much more um it's much more my
style i think i don't know what it comes
across in the film
a lot of actors i've talked to talk
about you know wanting to play roles
that scare them yes
get a sense of that yourself i mean
totally yeah i mean and that can come in
it
yeah definitely that can come in many
many ways you know a challenge is
is is a challenge for many different
reasons it doesn't have to be you know i
think people kind of want to go you know
i play a crazy character who does loads
of crazy stuff but actually like a
challenge can be in like an intimate
scene with somebody where it's just you
two in a room talking and finding out
what you want from each other um
a challenge can come you know in in
terms of different parts i this was a
big challenge for me because i felt a
lot of pressure is the only kind of
british
actor with you know a huge american and
south african team like i you know the
accent was i just wanted to like really
nail the accent and you know the loads
of different pressures your fight
training and horse riding training it
was you know it was a big
it was a big leap but um
hopefully i did it justice we'll just
find out yeah
oh you pulled it off so thank you good
thank you
thank you for talking to me about it i
appreciate it i thoroughly enjoyed the
movies thank you so much really nice to
meet you yeah